do you want to marry a virgin definitely
yes yeah
absolutely
i mean it's not the end-all thing but if
it's uh if i found the girl and i was
gonna like it regardless
i mean then yeah that's just i would say
would you guys be willing to like wait
then until you're married to sleep with
her
ooh
that's usually what comes with a virgin
like if if
she's she's usually waiting so like
typically
um like my friends that were virgins
when they got married like the dude
dated them for a year a year and a half
then they got married so he didn't do
anything with anyone else for a year
year and a half
this interesting question because like
personally i just don't think marriage
is advantageous i'm from canada right
and so the family court system they're
just not in the benefit of men so i just
don't believe in marriage but i think my
ideal partner that i'd want to like kind
of like emotionally spiritually settle
down with you know ideally would have a
lower body count what what if um
maybe marriage it doesn't have to be
like marriage in the church sure because
like those girls typically want to get
married in the church sure yeah i mean
would you be willing to wait like a year
year and a half to be with that girl i
think so yeah okay are you being honest
though
see so you're not gonna have to say your
stuff for the internet bro
if it was like an open relationship
dynamic and i could hook up with other
girls in the meantime no that's not how
it is
like okay the only reason i ask is a lot
of guys like say they want virgins but i
don't think they want what would come
with it and i know a lot of girls that
are virgins and did wait until they were
married because i went to catholic
school and just like different churches
i've been involved in i'm like i don't
think a lot of the guys that say they
want virgins would do the stuff they'd
be like they would want
i mean talk about your ex-girlfriend
yeah if you can
yeah talk about your ex-girlfriend
uh yeah my ex-girlfriend was a virgin
when i met her okay um
so it's not like and is she still a
virgin no i i took that okay very nice
yeah yeah
yeah but um i don't know i'm kind of on
board with what justin was saying about
the whole marriage system like i'd want
to do in the church for her and you know
have a big party and you know give her
the memories and whatnot
but in terms of like actually signing a
legal binding contract to a government i
that doesn't really interest me too much
yeah no i agree i don't think it's
advantageous for men like if i was a guy
i probably wouldn't want to get married
um
but it's interesting that what you say
about guys wanting a virgin but not
being willing to wait for the virginity
like that's like yeah a year and a half
sounds like a long time it does that
means we have to bump that marriage up
but do you think that's do you think
that's because you've experienced sex
already
um probably
yeah so now you know what it is you know
what you're going to be missing right
yeah
and i think that's a lot of what
because uh
remember the last show we had linda on
and she was a virgin
and um
i was speaking to her after the show
and it's just interesting
the way guys are like if
we speak out as statistics right
and
marriages
often work out if the two people that
get together in a marriage
are virgins yeah it's like the the
highest
success rate is when they're both
virgins yeah yeah
so if one has already experienced sex
and the other one hasn't then marriage
is less likely to work out
yeah i believe that
that makes sense
why are you laughing sorry because that
makes no sense to me whatsoever i really
wanna tell me why because like
i'm
like why would she even i just i
wouldn't not even consider someone how
how many like if someone's a virgin or
not if i like
i i i don't bump into any of you and say
hey are you a virgin no but when you're
getting to know somebody you would ask a
question no why
you don't want to know if the woman that
you're with is a virgin or she's had sex
with a hundred thousand men like
so you you would marry a girl that had
sex with a hundred guys
uh wow like why
why is the number like i i'm yeah sorry
i just yeah that's a completely abstract
concept to me do you want to talk about
pair bonding bro
no it was because i think i like yeah i
only discovered who you were
yesterday and yeah like yeah then like
even the idea of that yeah well i think
bonding is intriguing to me because it's
a completely foreign concept
it's just in my entire life yeah it's
just basically like the more partners
that a girl um has the more people she
compares him to typically and it makes
her less satisfied with the guy she's
with so for example if a girl is a
virgin when she's married she has an 80
chance of having a happy marriage after
10 years where if she slept with more
than five people it drops to a 30 chance
how are you how are you describing these
statistics to that
like what's the like how how do you
possibly prescribe an 80
statistical so so they they survey the
people later
so like how many people you slept with
when you got when you got married and
then later they come back and ask if
they're happy
are they reducing that to just sex and
saying that the reason the women are
comparing them to the past men is
specifically because of sexism well okay
they don't they don't really they don't
say in the study that it's because they
compare so i should say that's just like
based on like my like talking to people
um it's just based on how many partners
they've had so it drops down to 25
percent
it's just very homer simpson telling
kemp brockman that like 40 of all people
can make up statistics
like
so
so you don't see the you don't see the
sense in it so if if you think that
somebody has experienced a hundred men
for instance yeah if a woman's
experienced 100 men yes and then you're
101.
yeah you don't think that those 100 men
would um
she won't think about one of those 100
men
and not you and not you of course you
would but right exactly so that's that's
but that but it's a complete it's it's
it's a it's a fallacy it doesn't like it
it's not a comparable statistic
well of course it is because do you know
an alpha widow is
a what alpha widow an elf widow yeah so
a lot of women a lot of women go on
pearl you'll explain it better than i
would well it's basically like like
women
like to be with a guy that's the best
that they can get
and like they want to feel like they're
with who the best the best that they can
get and the problem is if a girl has a
guy that's at a certain caliber and then
she goes on to date somebody else
and she sees him as settled so a lot of
times women sleep up and then the person
that they marry isn't who they actually
want
and so there's like accounts of like
like even there's reddit threads of like
girls talking about how they
you know married one guy and they miss
their husband
or not sorry they miss their
ex-boyfriend from college or whoever it
was
but what is why does sex
or how many people they've slept with to
determine that wouldn't it be other
factors because they were treated in a
relationship
you're right it's not it's not only sex
but yeah but if you if you've had a
hundred guys but not all of those are
going to be substantial relationships
not all those are going to be comparable
to say the person you're with right if
it's one specific person right no
different for one person sleeping with
one person and comparing that to that
person right
what do you excuse so say if they um had
only slept with saved like five people
before they met the person they made
right um regardless of whether they
slept with a hundred or five there's
still that one boyfriend that they'd
compared to
you're actually right you're actually
correct with that it's not it's not
necessarily only about the number like
if you know the first person you slept
with was michael b jordan i think it's
going to be hard to live up with up to
that if that's your first boyfriend so
it's not necessarily about the number
but when you go up to a hundred it's
like the more chances of there being a
guy that you can't live up to i think
increases i think if women are actually
honest they all know that one guy in
their head that they probably won't say
there's that one guy that they know who
we're actually talking about i don't
know who he is but you do i think it's
it's depending on how you view your past
relationships for me there's no one in
my life i would really want to go back
to because i understand why it didn't
work out and and it worked out didn't
work out for specific reasons and i'm
not quite frankly that person anymore
and i also think it's dependent on the
circumstances of how women are sleeping
with these different men right if
they're not entering into emotional
commitments or you know why they're
sleeping around these sorts of things
and then they change the head space that
they're in then i don't think body count
has an impact on who their future
partner might be based on just
like self-awareness as many of you know
i was just banned on tac and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible